[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to so this
is the thing if you have kids or grew up
in the early 2000s you're probably
familiar with the straight-to-dvd film
the search for Santa Paws that's search
for Santa Paws you didn't think a name
this cute wasn't snatched earlier did
you but the real Ghostbuster did and we
got what is still constantly downloaded
on streaming sites advertised at DVD
shops and rented at the ancient temples
known as rental stories Before we jump
into this let's go into a little history
because Santa Paws kinda has a Cinematic
Universe the movie Believe It or Not
came from the film Air Bud the late 90s
flick about a dog could play basketball
I guess it was popular enough that
warranted no you need to cut to me when
I say that warranted several sequels
including Air Bud golden receiver Air
Bud world pup yeah
Air Bud seventh-inning fetch doll and
Air Bud Spike's back where we find out
dog Vader is his father
we got spin-off DVD movies about ear
buds offspring called air buddies this
was a big hit so as Disney does we got a
ton of spin-off films from that too
including space buddies super buddies
and you guessed it Santa buddies from
there we got another spinoff series
because this is the Star Trek of epic
puppy sagas and that series was called
the search for Santa Paws a prequel to
Santa buddies and arguably the most
popular of the films cry see what's
saying these titles does with that so
don't give a heads up I surprisingly
haven't seen most of the previous films
including Santa buddies but judging by
how many people pull this film out for
their kids every season I'm assuming
many others haven't either
I'm just looking at override zone to see
if it's worthy of the attention it's
gotten with that said get your
gingerbread kibble ready as we take a
look at the search for a Santa Paws it
starts off as Santa's work motel as the
credits roll the elves are singing and I
suddenly realize how many dogs are gonna
be tortured by hobby lobby's leftovers
one this welcome yes you know I also
think it was brave to cast Hugo Weaving
as Santa
mostly his eyebrows give children
nightmares but those will quickly be
intercepted by the scary CG mouths on
most of the dogs who provided the dogs
for this oh I don't know movie you've
seen how he's treated kittens in the
jerk as well as the gender confusion
he's pushed in Bowfinger
you let those dogs figure out themselves
themselves Santa Claus was a friggin
opera even the dog probably has an
aria in them just arrived by North Pole
Express richer kind you're better than
this I don't even need to check the
credits I know it's you
first you're asked to kill a cat's voice
and now a dog you're not gonna fade away
like Bing bong you're funny and I still
believe in you it looks like a friend
named mr. hucklebuckle died and weirdly
enough they put a lot of depressing
attention on this mr. hucklebuckle enjoy
passing on your message to the children
of new york the joy of a life of service
I've sent you the birthday present from
mr. hucklebuckle that he had hoped to
give you himself Santa Paws it applause
I mean come on they're supposed to be
like cute little puppies in this Oh God
is that dog stuffed mr. hucklebuckle was
a great ambassador for the Santa Clause
the corpse of his beloved pet will be
our Yule Log in his honor
well that was off-putting ly depressing
as he seems hucklebuckle was a toy store
owner thank God I thought he was a
Christmas porn star as his grandson
checks out the abandoned shop with his
wife and a wise old black man well they
don't have enough from working Freeman
so I'll just say Bill Cobb's it's always
one of those two your grandfather left
you the key to the store we're gonna put
the building on the market immediately
there is however one stipulation
you have to watch all the buddy move oh
yeah oh yeah they need to operate the
store through one Christmas season
profitably before the deed can be
transferred it's what we lawyers call
the middle finger clause coincidentally
the same title as that Tim Allen Martin
short movie will keep the store open
through Christmas mr. Stewart and I'm
sure your children will love it here
we haven't been blessed with any
children
a squid fort I'll be back Christmas Day
mr. Putnam to bring up other awkward
social standings how's your finances you
get along with your parents do both you
agree on religion and politics so let's
see Santa's workshop has suffered a
death his grandson has to operate a
business he knows about and his
wife can't have kids any other
heartwarming stab in the nards you want
to start us off with great abandon girl
has left at an orphanage run by a cruel
bitch from The Devil Wears Prada it was
a Saturday morning cartoon
well since The Return to Oz of buddy
movies light the hell up genie
where's your salad oh good another
character we can feel sorry for
I do hope in this first 12 minutes
you're satisfied with the two seconds of
a cute puppy we shone new kid much cuter
than you and younger sure she'll go fast
okay you're making the Harry Potter
family look like fuller house miss snow
can't stand Christmas and none of us are
allowed to have it
we just decorate mrs. Hopewell in the
back we're weird she confiscate any toys
most of all she hates any kind of
singing okay and a wondering how she got
to be the head of this place isn't just
like a car shopping anti-oil what
happened to your parents
I neither Jamie's two but she still
thinks they're gonna comfort her they
are gonna come for me nobody's parents
are coming for them we're only 15
minutes in might as well now finally
focus on a dog
being some kind of magic icicle to bring
the toy dog to life and they call and
pause you and I are going to be best
friends for all eternity eternity how
long is that forever young no sorry with
the mood you've been going for I assume
that's the music you wanted let's try
this
yay the season enjoy I guess don't
forgive those kids with dead parents I
think they're trying to overcompensate
for how miserable this opening is
because now everybody laughs like a
friggin lunatic
[Music]
look at how scared he is of us creepy
hell demon well be it's Gary
uncomfortable at least we're finally
getting some laughs invent our God thang
this is supposed to be Disney's
equivalent of dogs barking jingle bells
stop trying to turn it into Angela's
Christmas ashes ever since mr.
hucklebuckle is passing Christmas spirit
has been out of whack in New York oh my
god even the dogs talk about death I
never thought I had to say this to Santa
Paws but somebody freaking smile so
Santa and paws go looking for another
ambassador to the Santa Claus and land
in the middle of the night in Central
Park and that's the last we ever saw
them he pumps into the owner of the
orphanage who loses her hat in the
street so paws tries to go retrieve it
oh no
well congratulations movie you killed
Santa only a half-hour in and you erase
the fat man I can't wait to see your
follow up movie where you assassinate
the Easter Bunny your second y'all gonna
help no don't worry it's not as bad as
all that
he just gets robbed yeah losing his bag
his icicle necklace and even his memory
I was hoping you could help me you see I
don't quite remember where I live or
anything else for that matter though I
do have a vague recollection of
conquering Martians pause also get
separated but Santa just happens to make
his way to hucklebuckle toys you know
across from America and what a stroke of
luck they're looking for a department
store Santa so can you start today
starker you're looking for work right
more like a home really gotcha out so
they get the real Santa Claus to be a
fake Santa Claus without realizing he's
the real Santa Claus it's like robbing
Peter to pay Paul doesn't make any sense
and they even offer him a place to stay
in the store because wouldn't you do
that for a guy you just met the two
girls sneak out and visit Santa in the
store what did she ask you for it wanted
me to get her
and will that red bike in the window I
have a strange urge to break into their
homes and eat their circular desserts
pause meanwhile comes across a group of
scrounging dogs to see if they know
where Santa is allow me to introduce
myself
I'm paws from the North Pole yeah mom
and I'd be the Tooth Fairy you expect me
to believe I didn't just clean the floor
with you a minute ago a dog catcher
grabs them though as the girls are
caught sneaking back in when you break
the rules you get to spend all night
down here in the basement you're staying
here and no dinner for you either okay
but can I at least see a dog scene that
goes over a minute in this film just for
that I'm showing you a grumpy cat
Christmas
[Applause]
[Music]
some pause uses his magic necklace to
break the others out and they decide to
help him now were your peeps we'll keep
an eye up for said real you did us a
solid line you'll be cool with us I got
some brothers in the flight guide
neighborhood and pretty sure they've
seen his face on the Happy Meal box
meanwhile somebody finally comes across
the sleigh in Central Park I think all
their antlers and hooves were probably
been stolen by this point and reindeer
tell the kid they're looking for Santa
we need you to find Santa Claus for us
Junior
okay never mind hey homeless guy keep
you help us find Santa
can I pause of course meets up with the
orphanage and talks with Quinn who says
she can lead him to Santa we can meet
here tonight and I can help you look her
sanity
oh come on can't one of them catch fire
or something it feels weird if none of
them are suffering meanwhile paws tries
to make things more festive
[Music]
you made this room 2% more magical
Santa's doing a great job bringing more
people into the store and reveals the
reason why someone wants told me that
the spirit of Christmas is embodied in
the hearts of children untouched as yet
by the fierce doubts and disappointments
of the adult world somebody else told me
it was Jesus but I think it was drunk
Quinton paws sneaked out of the
orphanage but what bad luck Santa just
happens to be on a break and wasn't
there that's not the real Santa night
watch Netflix I know he looks like the
guy from Big Trouble in Little China but
the little boy comes across Santa and
says his reindeer are waiting I don't
know if I'm the real Santa Claus or not
but here's a pin to thank you for your
persistence I believe someone very
special gave it to me so I'm giving it
to a kid who could easily be lying to me
it's safe it's kind of dumb in this
anyone else notice the girls at the
orphanage see paws and understand him
perfectly but will a mean that doesn't
believe in Santa so all she hears is
barking when it right here a Christmas
song I want to missed out there singing
in there please burn them because sure
this matches the depressing as hell
atmosphere we've had throughout most of
the movie
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a tone-deaf life for us weren't we
talking about death most of the time
[Music]
yeah it's hard to say but this upbeat
song sequence surprisingly doesn't go
with Santa Paws most of it was weirdly
mellow and downbeat and now suddenly
we're supposed to be like the greatest
showman on the Polar Express this looks
less like the majority of the movie we
got it more like a Disney Princess
commercial imagine discovering royal
treasures and entering the world of
Disney Princess dreams do come true
[Music]
dressing head-to-toe beautiful gowns now
you can own a Disney Princess unless
your caretaker finds her and burns her
alive in the furnace all this goes
together you're wrong if you don't think
so sure enough miss doubt comes in and
thinks Wilhemina started all this and
takes away the dogs gym clean up this
mess and take off those ridiculous
dresses now now I won't mention the
impossible wait could have gotten a room
like this just take those dresses off
knit so Macy's she also finds Quinn's
Christmas ornament and takes it away no
now get upstairs before you end up in
the basement too I'm sending it to my
dungeon for Christmas toys to tell me I
don't have that there's that depressing
as hell telling I'm familiar with in
this movie good lord for a second I
almost thought about liking something
why are you okay it's it's almost 9:15
Santa's feeling ill at the shop but it
looks like he's needed to be on camera
thank goodness
ABC wants to do a quick interview with
you on your break today Oh ABC aren't
they owned by Disney now only things
owned by Disney now not only do the kids
get to see Santa Claus pass out on the
verge of death but we also get this nice
little moment everything I love dies
everything I love dies everything I love
dies you do it
Santa Paws Santa Paws I don't know where
toy souls go when they burn so just a
recap santa dying children crying dog
burning sounds like the cover to a Nine
Inch Nails album le the head of locates
the orphanage and finds both Santa and
paws are fading away because their
necklace crystals are gone
he gets one back from the homeless guy
who stole it who now wants to help I
only need to get the other crystal to
pause before he burns good news only his
head burned off
he didn't need that right they get him
the crystal and paws comes back to life
they go to Huckle buckles and let the
owners know what's going on Santa lost
his magic crystal and his health must
have been deteriorating ever since that
dog is talking I see you believe in the
Christmas spirit
or that ass have you had this morning
takes a while to kick in they call the
social worker to have missed out remove
from the kids which of course calls for
a home alone stunt Oh honestly I'm
surprised that's the only one they have
in this movie and the others go to take
Santa from the hospital to the North
Pole the security in this place is as
good as the one in Halloween two winos
Michael Myers but surprisingly fed in
this experiment of hopeless misery she's
gonna be okay the search for Santa Paws
just asked that question what is wrong
with you
but pause offers up his crystal knowing
it'll slowly turn him back into a toy we
wish you a Merry Christmas we have to
get back to the North Pole at once only
the great Christmas icicle can save paws
now you know that actor is doing a good
job when he could say that line without
making me laugh so they do exactly that
but it seems like it doesn't work no in
any other movie I'd say this is a fake
out but in this one who goddamn knows
they pull a Pokemon the first movie
though in Santa's tears somehow bring
him back to life and on steroids
apparently from now on your name will be
shacked up hood now we really can't be
best friends for all eternity Santa
Claus just spend the Icicle breaks and
kills them all hey you know this movie
would do that Quinn and Wilhemina are of
course adopted by the hucklebuckle and
everyone seems happy they need a home
honey that is the greatest Christmas
present I could ever imagine
no dude she said think she can still
probably come up with a few things so
the other dogs become honorary elves and
Santa goes on his Christmas sleigh ride
this is most joyous there's Christmas
magic to spread let's do this together
Santa Claus your blank expression
reflects all the Christmas magic this
movie could muster even wise black man
makes one more appearance I trust you to
have had an eventful Christmas season Oh
mr. Stewart these are the newest
additions to our family that's will and
this is Quinn Christ you push those out
fast so the hucklebuckle is now owned
the store and they decide to keep it
open Merry Christmas
got your wish that's rad I talked to
signs it'll be the name of the next
sequel sign buddies the script was
halfway written the minute I've read
that this was the weirdest thing I've
ever been in and that was the search for
Santa Paws Alamut it's not at all what I
was expecting what were you expecting
I don't know credit for trying to be a
little harsher than what people would
think it was gonna be I didn't like a
lot of the actors in particularly the
guy who played Santa who you might have
noticed a lot of character roles in the
past but it's still not very good mostly
because a lot of those heavy moments
have to be followed by a charming story
that can support it and this story reads
like well a cheesy direct-to-dvd
spin-off nevertheless it was a little
better than I thought it had any right
to be but it had the right to be a
soulless corporate shell so take that
for what it's worth this is a bizarre
special that wasn't as bad as I thought
but still bad I doubt people are gonna
stop watching it anytime soon so it
truly seems like every dog has this
Christmas Day but Jesus did it have to
be that harsh I mean it's the search for
Santa Paws it's like putting Nazis and
Nutcracker it just makes no sense I'm
the Nostalgia Critic I ever met what are
we reviewing next week
[Music]
[Applause]
see you're going to die
hey everybody dog walker here doing the
charity shout out and this week we've
done this charity before but it's very
popular around December it's Toys for
Tots and so what I was gonna do is I was
gonna show the one that we did before
talking about all the great stuff about
and I forgot there's actually a funny
story behind this one when we did this
charity so I'm actually going to show
you the the funny story before and then
you're gonna see the charity but either
way go to Toys for Tots you all know it
it's a wonderful organization donate and
enjoy this story I have a funny story
for you while we were shooting this
review we were outside about to shoot a
scene with nostalgia critic and Santa
Christ and this car pulls up and they
pull ran to our parking spot and we
don't recognize the people and they get
out and we say can we help you and they
say Toys for Tots no no no we're not
Toys for Tots looking us like are you
sure we said yeah we're sure why would
we know where Toys for Tots are and they
said well cuz you got a guy dressed like
Santa Claus there so bizarrely enough
they were driving around looking for
Toys for Tots that we happen to come
outside with a guy dressed as Santa
Claus and I took it as a sign so the
charity we are doing this week is Toys
for Tots a lot of you have heard this
charity before this is a charity that
gets toys to kids who are not able to
have toys this Christmas a lot of people
donate in December but for next year
it's good to know that they actually
start in October and November as well
the more toys they can get the more kids
can have these toys and these are
children that either come across hard
times or the parents come across hard
times and are unable to get gifts I mean
there are so many people out there
they're just going through such rough
patches right now and just are not able
to do something that every kid deserves
every kid deserves to have presents
around Christmastime and these are
people that make it happen it's of
course done by the Marine Corps but they
also have so many good sponsors behind
they have Disney they have mace
they have toys-r-us all these people try
so hard to raise awareness and you see
that poster everywhere of Santa with the
Marine uniform in the closet and if you
even go to their YouTube channel Marine
Toys for Tots you'll see that so many
kids benefit from this and so many
celebrities get behind this as well and
it's just a good cause because every
little kid deserves presents on
Christmas and by donating toys or money
to this wonderful charity you can help
make that happen so whether it's
donating online or just driving around
until you see a guy dressed like Santa
please definitely take the time to look
into it buy a gift for a child less
fortunate and help them have a wonderful
holiday donate to Toys for Tots Santa
Christ approves
[Music]
you